[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben weiter geht's mit
meiner subway reihe ich habe euch
gezeigt wie das original brot zubereitet
und jetzt brauchen wir einen gebührenden
belag dafür und ich mache heute ein
thomas ab also ganz einfach thunfisch
mag ich sehr sehr gerne und dafür habe
ich hier mein esel
da könnt ihr auch die light variante
nehmen ich hab mitleid variante dann
natürlich thunfisch und das verriet
jetzt einfach miteinander die ganz
genaue angabe schreibe ich euch wie nach
unten in die video beschreibung wie
gesagt das verriet ihr miteinander
dann kommt ja nur salz pfeffer spritzer
zitronensaft und wenn ihr möchtet ein
bisschen paprika flocken dazu und das
war es schon
[Musik]
also bei subway ist das alles noch ein
bisschen feiner der tun würde ich glaube
das liegt einfach an den großen
maschinen
es ist dann wie püriert ich persönlich
finde so mega mega gut deshalb lasse ich
das jetzt auch so
das war jetzt auch eine superschnelle
füllung führt zum beispiel wenn ihr
einfach mal lust habt thunfisch belag
drauf und dann mit käse überbacken
richtig lecker aber wir sind noch beim
thema tabu daher werde ich jetzt meinen
sie's oregano brot einmal längs
aufschneiden und dann nach herzenslust
belegen und ich habe auch schon die
street online soße zubereitet das video
kommt dann morgen und ich mag das
generell mag diese suite on ihn so sei
auch in verbindung mit thunfisch oder
material was auch bald kommt aber ich
glaube ich belegt jetzt erst mal nämlich
heute noch nichts gegessen
[Musik]
willkommen bei subway was darf ich ihnen
denn für ein brot anbieten
daran hätte gerne schießen
zufälligerweise ja ich habe sogar schon
auf bestellungen ganz ja ein ganz 31 cm
sappl habe ich ja darf den scheiben käse
dazu seien ja ok sondern belegen das
erste mit scheiben käse und dann dein
belag ist ja ganz zufälligerweise haben
wir heute unser eben tun habe lag im
angebot stehen das okay machen war und
wie wir es ja projektteams portion ihrer
organe büttel auch gewähren also im
backofen
[Musik]
so jetzt kommen die belege darfst jetzt
noch das wären was ich will ihn haben
doch auch so wenn du willst also ich
denke mal salat das kommt mir immer als
erstes braucht okay was haben sie ja ich
kenne ich so gut ich habe einfach alles
rausgeholt was du immer besser bremst
[Musik]
ja weil hier so sah das denn sein okay
ja es wird an ihnen sehr gerne das noch
ein bisschen salz und pfeffer sein okay
okay das richtig gut
[Musik]
perfekt hey boss ich doch das ist nur
für personal was machen sie hinter die
theke ein einstellungstest was mein
lieblings cookie sorte sie haben den job
leute jetzt sogar billiger werden
jetzt probieren wir all das ist ganz
kurzes 1.50 uhr wir haben so hunger wir
haben heute nur gestört
also von der dicke von brot ist schon
mega so das 1 1 er willst du gucke das
ist wirklich ein zulässiges ab ob sich
auf jeden fall nun bauleute schmeckt so
gut dass bundes soweit das boot muss
auch soweit sein es darf nicht knusprig
hätten so weich sein subway brote sind
weich kann sich nun gespannt was ultra
lecker es ist deluxe also wie sagt man
so dadurch das interesse
das zeugt von qualität das zeigt einfach
dass es subway geld das jetzt auch immer
besser bringt wie fertig belegen stehen
geschmack gestoppt also ist man mit
griechisch becker das ist in meinen
augen
ich weiß nicht wieso sollen so aber ich
finde ich mir doch bis das wasser durch
das ist doch ganz normal dass du es
sagst weil es ist halter selbst gemacht
das ist auch vollkommen in ordnung
weshalb wohl ist natürlich alles ein
bisschen auf masse und so und ein
bisschen auch industrie dabei klar sie
schon mit sicherheit auch was frisches
dabei aber auch komplett homemade hallo
also alles richtig gemacht dass nach
irgendwelche läuft nie wieder so zog ich
für solche schwer
das einzige was bisschen trick ist das
paket aber es geht auch schnell so
interesse
50 sagt ist doch nix super super schnell
belegt und ihr könnt auch ganz andere
sachen noch drauf belegen alles ist ihr
mögt und ich würde mal sagen leute
auftrag macht ganz viel spaß dabei und
schreibt mir unbedingt in die kommentare
was euer lieblings ab ist und vielleicht
mache ich das ja als nächstes wir sehen
uns dann beim nächsten mal haben sie du
musst dein bei sap damit unsere
verabschiedung machen konnte
bis zum nächsten mal auf geht s kitchen
ganz richtig lecker
[Musik]